Speaker 1: Yesterday, I did a couple of segments
about the targeting of trans people and drag shows
and the LGBT community in the wake of the horrible
shooting in Nashville, Tennessee. One of the
things I mentioned but didn't end up having time
for and I want to talk about it now, is the claim
that trans people are targeting Christians.
Now, before we move on to the generality of
Tucker Carlson making this claim, I do want to
remind folks that the shooter in Nashville who
was trans had a history with that school. And so
it's very hard in that particular case to make the
argument that trans people and the movement is
targeting Christians. But even more generally,
I'm going to argue with you, argue to you, I'll
argue with you if you want to argue with me. But
I will argue to you that the claim that the trans
movement is targeting Christians is is absurd.
And in fact, LGBTQ people are way more likely to
be the victims of violence, including from those
who say, I don't like you because of my Christian
worldview than they are to be the perpetrators of
violence at all. Never mind against Christian
individuals. Rolling Stone article says Tucker
Carlson Claims Trans movement is Targeting
Christians amid calls for gun control.
The article says LGBTQ people are much more
often likely to be the victims of targeted
mass violence than perpetrators. Tucker Carlson
did this nonsense on his opening monologue. I'm
going to play it for you and then we will discuss.
Speaker 2: The trans movement is targeting
Christians, including with violence.
Speaker 1: That is wrong.
Speaker 2: Most Christian leaders
in this country don't want to admit
that admitting it might force them to
take deeply unfashionable positions.
But it is true, and anyone who's paying attention
knows that it's true. And so, like most true
things at this point, it is officially suppressed.
Speaker 1: Now, that is also part of the story.
Part of getting your audience to
believe in saying untrue things
is priming them that the reason they might
not hear this insane, untrue thing elsewhere
isn't because it's untrue. It's because it's
being suppressed elsewhere. Which, of course,
it's not that the trans movement's vendetta
against Christianity is being suppressed.
It's that it doesn't exist anywhere beyond
resentment over those who weaponise their
Christian faith against trans people.
Speaker 2: Here, for example,
is Joe Biden yelping again about how it's all
your fault when these tragedies happen because
you've got guns at home. This is from yesterday.
Speaker 3: We have to do more to stop gun violence
in our communities apart, ripping a soul.
This nation, which is a very solid nation.
And we we have to do more to protect our schools
so they aren't turned into prisons. You know,
the shooter in this situation reportedly had two
assault weapons and a pistol, two AK 47. So I call
on Congress again to pass my assault weapons ban.
Speaker 2: So we're going to prevent you from
learning why the shooter did it. And we don't
have to guess because she wrote a whole manifesto
about why she did it. And we know that she
did that because she told a friend of hers
on Instagram that she did it. But we can't see
it. We can only talk about the guns. We can't
know what kind of drug she was taking, what
kind of hormones or SSRI or benzodiazepines.
Speaker 1: Whatever it is. Ben, I hate to tell
you folks, benzos causing a mass shooting does
not sound like the most informed take I've
ever heard. And it of course, it's coming from
Tucker Carlson, not from a medical professional.
Speaker 2: We can only talk about the guns. Pass
my assault weapons ban. That'll fix the problem.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, we can talk about much
more than the guns. If they want to talk about
mental illness, we should talk about mental
illness. And I do. But they don't want to actually
fund access to mental health treatment. If they
want to talk about the toxic gun culture of the
United States. I would gladly talk about that.
They will never even bring that up. They don't
want to acknowledge that. And yes, we should
also talk about the guns. Now, there's one other
aspect to this. Not only is this brazenly untrue
that the trans movement is targeting Christians.
The trans movement doesn't want violent rhetoric
or discrimination from anybody, no matter the
origins of that. In some cases it is Christianity
that is being, I would argue, being misused.
They would say it's just we're just looking at
scripture. I would say it is being misused
to target the trans community. But there's
another aspect to this. To some extent,
many of these folks see not being Christian
as hostile to Christianity. You can be
non-religious. That doesn't mean you're
targeting Christianity. You could be Muslim
or Jewish or Buddhist or whatever. And not be
targeting Christianity. But a lot of these folks,
the mere absence of Christianity is targeting
Christianity. And this is part of the problem for
some of the for a wing of the American evangelical
community. Simply not being an evangelical
Christian, they claim, is an attack on their
faith and less thing. There are also trans people
who are Christian. I think it's important to say.